the end of berry Football Club feels
like a bereavement for some fans after
134 years in the Football League it's
all over
tied up with it decades of memories
victories defeats even marriage
proposals just Stephanie though you know
got engaged over that's my fiancee and
that's it it's not it's not family
it's business it's just money that's all
he want the venues that we have in
Barrie that pubs and chickpeas and
whatnot they making money the community
of Barry is making money just by it was
playing here every Saturday so that in
itself is gonna suffer by us being
kicked out I believe the day had begun
hopefully hundreds of volunteers
preparing the stadium for what they
thought would be Barry's first home game
of the season on Saturday owner Stephen
Dale had bought the club for one pound
and he'd been set to sell it to CNN
sporting risk but with just hours until
the AFL deadline the deal collapsed just
last season Barry were promoted to Ligue
1 now they become the first FA Cup
winning team to be expelled from the
Football League Barry FC is just 15
miles from Manchester United and
Manchester City two of the richest
football clubs in the world
questions will now be asked about
whether they could have done more to
save Barry FC and whether that is their
responsibility down the road in Bolton
the outlook is also bleak they have been
given 14 days to avoid the same fate
shake we already said there's something
rotten in football and I think there is
something rotten in football a football
is our national game it belongs to the
people not to a few individuals who want
to make a few Bob out of it Barry all
hope was lost fans left to contemplate
life without their beloved club Martha
Kellner Sky News Barry